what an introduction
actually this um
reminder to me that
I'm Brown
[Applause]
is very Timely
because
I've become as some of you know a
leading spokesman for white supremacy in
the United States
so sometimes I actually look in the
mirror and I'm slightly surprised
that I'm still Brown
actually it reminds me of a true story
that happened to me when I first came to
America as an exchange student
in 1978 I was I lived in Arizona went to
public school
I lived with a with a host family
it was a rotary youth Exchange program
and about a month or so after I had been
in the country my host parents said to
me hey Dinesh there's um there's a
homecoming dance at your high school
and you um you should ask someone to go
and I said well you know I'm
I don't know anyone all that well I
haven't been here all that long I think
I should pass they were like no Dinesh
it's it's an American tradition
you must do it
so I said okay and I approached a young
woman in my class so a blonde as I
recall
and I said hey um would you like to go
to the homecoming dance
and she said uh sure but I have to ask
my parents I will tell you tomorrow
so the next day I went up to her and I
said well um
what did they say
and she said who
I said well you're your parents
and she said um about what
and of course I had to take in this
extremely embarrassing situation and try
to figure out what exactly was going on
and then suddenly hit me with a shock of
Horror
I had approached the wrong girl
this incident has has troubled me
slightly over the years
I I mean I wouldn't say it's a full
explanation of me
but it's it's haunted me a little and
I've tried to think about why I could
make such an elementary mistake and I
think I finally figured it out
I think I was I was actually
subscribing to a very common third world
fallacy
which of course is the idea that all
white women look alike
I should probably save this anecdote for
White History Month
when it will come in it'll be very
poignant
well I'm honored to be here delighted to
speak on behalf of Hillsdale
Hillsdale represents so much that is
good and these days
important and rare
in in America
and for me my American Experience
has a lot to do with really falling in
love with liberal education that's
ultimately what took me to the Claremont
Institute where I first met Larry this
would have been gosh 1983 the year I
graduated from Dartmouth
I'm really not exactly sure how I got to
Dartmouth as a foreign student from
India I'm from Arizona
Dartmouth as some of you know and there
are a couple of Dartmouth grads who came
up to me here tonight was the college
founded in New Hampshire by um a
clergyman
really for the education of the Indians
but of course that referred to the
Native Indians Native Americans
sometimes I think I may have just
misread the catalog
but
I'm a product of the Reagan Revolution
and
[Applause]
and the different America that it
represented in fact
Reagan's America was in some ways the
America of the founders
Reagan often spoke about a society that
was focused on the individual
the family
the local community
the church
and then the country
and these were multiple associations
that Reagan defended Reagan wasn't just
an individualist he spoke about all
these things
and it's very striking now that we
realize that the left
is against all of them
so
I would like to tell you that I'm still
living in Reagan's America
but that Kinder gentler America that we
recall and that many of us yearn for
and quite frankly the America that was a
formative
influence that made us into who we are
politically
that America is is gone
and there might be a way to get it back
but it's not the way we think
it's actually not the Reagan way
I I think if Reagan were alive today he
would be
a fish out of water
he would be unsettled
by how roiled divisive our politics have
become
but I do think there is one man who if
alive today would not be
Royal would not be
discombobulated would not be
um thrown out
and that would and that's Lincoln
why
because the waters were even more roiled
in the late 1850s
and of course the early 1860s
now
the question I um
want to set before you tonight is this
one
what gives how have we gotten to this
pass
if it is the case that we are
a decent country founded on decent
principles and we've got a constitution
that was written by the wisest people
who ever came together with a deep
understanding of human nature
why is none of that protecting us right
now
how is it the case that we not only have
this divided country but ruthless
assaults on our basic liberties
that seem to go
unchallenged unblocked
and we find ourselves fighting for
things that should not even be up for
majority referendum
foreign
how did we get here
and where does the other side get the
extreme hutzpah
to do this to us
what makes them think they can get away
with it
to this answer I offer a perhaps
surprising answer
and that is
the reason
that we are in this situation
is mainly
because of us
and it is because of the observation of
us
by the other side that they behave the
way that they do
Larry talked a moment ago about
education
and education begins in observation
You observe
You observe your political adversary you
check him out
we sometimes hear these days the phrase
critical race Theory
well let's let's not worry about the
Race part of it
the critical part of it begins with
careful and acute observation
and this I would submit the left has in
fact been doing to us for the past 25
years
and what have they seen and what have
they concluded
well they've basically concluded that
the
conservatives
the Republicans the Patriots the
Christians
are the party of the nice guys
they're the party of the people who want
to get along
they're the party who say things like
turn the other cheek
they're the party that would rather Live
and Let Live they believe in Freedom
and um they're also the principled party
they take great pride in not doing
things because they are held back by
principle
they strive to be better than themselves
if you will
and the left concludes
these are the perfect people for us to
trample
why
because this is the party of the Namby
pambis and the and the losers
and the people who will never do to us
what we intend to do to them
we can rest says the left secure in the
knowledge that if we take away their
first amendment rights and they have
supreme power
they will never take away ours
we can pack the court
let's add four more members because
we're absolutely positive that even if
they came into power they wouldn't pack
the court they believe it should be nine
they're they're committed to nine so
even if our project fails no big deal
because it's going to impose no
political cost on us whatsoever
look at the way that our nominees the
left's nominees and their nominees
show up
before the court to be to be chosen by
to be not ratified by the Senate
their nominees come forward and say in
advance
even though we believe X Y and Z on
religious or ideological grounds
we have no intention of imposing any of
those values or principles on the law
in fact we will consciously and
deliberately set them aside
we will be governed by what the
Constitution says and if the
Constitution is ambiguous we will
excavate the original intentions of the
framers
now
I mean this is Amy Coney Barrett right
before the Senate my Catholicism will
have nothing to do with the way I make
decisions
now can you imagine
Elena Kagan or Sotomayor or
my lesbianism will have nothing to do
with the way I make decisions on the
court
they'd never say that they wouldn't
dream of saying that why because it is
understood that they're on the court for
that reason
to precisely impose those ideological
principles on the country
so it's almost as if we are forswearing
the use of our own weapons in advance
putting them down
and they when they look for nominees try
to think about why even though we've had
it the vast majority of nominees to the
court have been Republicans going all
the way back to the 70s and 80s
why is it the case that only Now 50
years later we have a narrow majority
why haven't we had a majority all the
way
because we couldn't count on Sandra Day
O'Connor and then we couldn't count on
Suitor and we couldn't count in Anthony
Kennedy
then you can't count on Roberts
so
so this is our predicament when the left
nominates judges they we consider things
like does this judge have a deep love of
the law
do they do they enjoy learning are they
dedicated to the understanding of the
original motives of the founders
the left doesn't care about any of this
they ask this question will this nominee
vote on all critical issues our way with
euclidean certainty
they don't sit around how's Ruth Bader
Ginsburg gonna vote
how is you know judge katanji Jackson
gonna vote they know how they're gonna
vote
they're picked on the court to vote
now
the Deep state
what makes the left think they can
deploy the organs of the IRS
the FBI
the um the doj against political
opponents
again they do it because they know
that we never will
we wouldn't dream of it
if Obama went after me for making my
film about Obama is it even conceivable
not even that bush but anyone Trump
DeSantis anyone would dream of arresting
Michael Moore
locking him up finding something to get
them on some tax violation or some other
violation
interview him for seven hours lying to a
federal official I mean the federal
statute book is an accordion
once you know who you're going after
it's not that hard to find out a way to
do it but we wouldn't do it
that's the point
we don't believe because we are two
principled
we hold ourselves back
but now we Face an interesting problem I
think and it's a problem that goes right
to the core issue of the American
founding
which is how can we expect at the end of
the day of basic Liberties to be
protected at all by a piece of paper